edition
these clips have been selected by none
other
than my wife so i've of course taken on
the challenge
because i never ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever laughed how many episodes
have we done
a billion and i ain't cracking now let's
do it
first clip is hungry micropat enjoys his
dinner
so rachel's just caught this girl's
waddled back to um to feed her but she's
very hungry as you can tell
busy yeah would you like some food
that's not a laugh oh she's hungry
alright
so what's in that rachel i'm smiling
because this is such a marxian
i'm laughing at something else not the
video itself so it doesn't count
right say thank you blended food
meal worms some vitamin powders
yeah threes okay um
to take care of their teeth and i've
actually mixed it with
some microbial milk which we make up
we're not getting a bat it's not
happening
yeah i'm the man of the house
it looks like a pug i think that's what
it looks like egg edgar when eats
yeah she's a she's a bigger juvenile
okay some more
okay okay look at you
storms here so it's just it's just very
hungry as you can see
thank um she'll take nearly a whole meal
all right next hill what is this crazy
chica call okay creatures and i just
found chicago
yard oh yeah i forgot to mention this is
animal edition
so it fits that hackers here these are
all uh animal clothes which is my
weakness to be fair
but i'm strong enough i know i can do it
so this is pretty cool
i hope it's alive because usually you
don't find them alive
no they're creepy looking
did you hear that wow
okay i need to get something to play so
angry that was awesome
wow i was scared of my life why are kids
so fearless
and i got a phone call to put it in
don't put it in the cup
don't do it it's angry it's gonna eat
you
[Applause]
okay so it's pretty loud yeah but i'm
gonna have to touch it
no you don't what are you on about
oh i definitely heard it
did you hear that giant sound he made
all right what's next again
a guinea pig fight oh they're all kind
of information as well
oh i've seen this this is phenomenal i
love this click
i don't know if maritza showed it to me
already but he does a full-on
jojo charge attack
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it doesn't count if i've already seen it
everyone knows this get out of here
look at this charge there whoa
that's it all right that's been it then
i had enough for you you messed with my
[ __ ] lettuce again mate
guinea pigs don't mess around again hey
you got a thing or two to learn
useless pug you would never hurt anyone
you're so weak
you're so weak and pathetic look at you
this face could never hurt anything
you're so weak you're so weak
pathetic show them how strong you are
show them your bicep
damn damn oh
he's not even he's not even worth that
all right let's watch more so far zero
laughs
no study dance
oh the legs
my fire alarm is out of battery
okay fine i like it
[Laughter]
birds are cute birds are cute say it
loud
say it iggy what are you so excited
about you want to go
all right she got me once but i got
three strikes
okay lucky eats a banana bananas are
good
they are potassium gotta get it
oh no it's a banana it's a banana
what's it meant
[ __ ] where's the moment
[Laughter]
it worked it
damn it i'm weak
[Laughter]
oh that's a great clay
furiously attacks banana gets like
one gram banana
oh that's great fine i lose one what are
you gonna do
sue me oh what is that b oh i've seen
this
it's horrifying youtube don't demand it
oh god oh that mouth that mouth looks so
yeah yeah yeah
cute bunny uh-huh sexy bunny
oh god it's starting to horror movies oh
god what have i done
it goes from sexy to horrifying so fast
no one's
ready for it mr bubbs oh mr bugs i
recognize that
is he the crazy dog
[Laughter]
baby boy
there's a demon inside that dog it's
trapped and it comes out
when they call you a good boy oh
this is cute
[Music]
oh blessed video
[Laughter]
you're welcome cheers to you didn't
laugh we thoroughly enjoyed oh wait
there's more
[Music]
and they have the adopted audacity to
say dogs don't smile
how explain they scientific
i i am never listening to scientists how
loud he coming
oh lord
big boy it finally came
the big one would you rather be fit or
fat
why not both
oh my god dude our cat growing up i
swear was a mega chunker
maybe even olaudi coming he weighed like
eight kilos or something
ungodly i remember coming home from
school and
i would enter the kitchen where the cat
flap is and he's just standing there
half his face out so humiliated because
he got stuck
obviously good times i was an [ __ ]
cat but you know
little closer he's going for it there
he keeps going can't stop there
oh cute that's adorable
loved it very much have i given up on
the life you lose
yes because i clearly failed oh it's
it's jambolas oh
they're in the hot spring we saw this on
the anime euro camp
apparently in nature they go in hot
springs and i didn't believe it but here
i am looking at it
incredible is that lemon
oh homie's just chilling what a life to
live in
he goes in the bucket bro you're not
gonna fit
get out of here don't even try oh okay
i was wrong oh that's so cute
i stand corrected yeah
that was amazing
they're so chill this is the life i want
to live
right here
no oh you killed him
[Laughter]
cat too strong shut the [ __ ] up boy
why did you do this oh it breaks my
heart
no the witness is shocked
can't be like i don't appreciate your
tone okay this is a must-watch oh
because it's eggy
oh eggy
okay stop being so depressed look it's
right there i can see him in there
yeah he got freaked out by maya's finger
one night it was so funny
no
we gotta watch that together again look
he's fine he's stronger than ever you
can tell he's had no brain damage
because oh how awake he looks
okay let's watch it together
hey look how pathetic you are look look
look he's looking so intently
oh you're you're a tough dog now huh uh
you're a tough dog what was that
what a loser
[Laughter]
hey hey hey hey relax
relax i know it's embarrassing
i understand but you got uh oh he's he's
out of here
no one thinks you're tough big guy
oh my god we also have one of our dog
maya that's so
funny it was a vine it was a quite
popular vine for a while i gotta find it
here it is
find it uh we'll have to add some other
audio in unfortunately but maya wanted
to get up on the bed
look at her oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
you see the fear in her eyes wait
why does she have two eyes what the [ __ ]
oh okay there we go it looks like she
had two eyes there for a second what the
[ __ ]
oh bless pug breaks my heart
and today no more edgar oh i'm sorry am
i bothering you
you're oh don't make my comment oh look
so older shut up
well that was your life you lose animal
edition hosted
co-hosted by march selected by marzia
very well done
appreciate it hope you enjoyed smash
like subscribe for more videos
see you tomorrow bye bye bye bye hey
and you can't go to the zoo you need to
go to the [ __ ] loop
i got something something for you and
you leave
[Music]
gonna go with it aloo i got something
for you
you